inflation 6.2 percent how off is that
number
um that's the number they're telling you
and that's the scary part
you know so i mean you want to talk
about an elephant in the room kind of
scenario
um
here you are looking at 6.2 percent
the equity markets priced at 2 or 3
the fixed income markets priced at 1.5
if you're looking at the 10-year
treasury so
you know for me i'm just looking around
the the marketplace and saying
how are how are people not talking about
this elephant in the room of a 300 400
basis point negative spread on pretty
much everything on the planet
right and i just don't see it going away
and i know i'm i'm way more
i'm a little different than danny boy as
far as how i'm looking at things
when you think when you think about
these metrics right uh
the 6.2 percent inflation let's just say
we'll give them the benefit of the doubt
that's the real number it's probably not
i think you and i agree on that but
let's just say it is
yeah
the traditional assets
and traditional asset allocation what 60
70 percent of it's dead in the water at
six at six percent inflation right like
even if that was the real number every
bonds underwater pretty much almost all
commodities are either break even or
underwater on a real return basis and so
you're basically left with public
equities that likely are overvalued from
a multiple bases or you can go look at
something like bitcoin but like other
than that like where the hell do you go
real estate
you said every single bond on the planet
is negative yielding and not by a little
bit but like a lot
and that's what the number they're
telling you
so now let's let's
pull up the lynn alden sailor you know
i've been throwing out the m2 argument
really kind of being like the real
metric
of how much the basement's happening and
you're in double digits so that number
might be twice as as bad as what what
they're telling you
so and you mentioned commodities so like
when i'm thinking of like a commodity
business
like their margins suck they're after
tax margins you know three percent
i don't i it depends on which you know
commodity you're talking but most of
these commodities after tax their
margins are like three maybe five
percent at best so like how in the world
are all these companies which make up
the business around the world
gonna possibly survive in these
circumstances which kind of leads to
like the bigger point is the supply
chain issues that we're seeing right now
a function of the influx of fiat that
was added or are we actually seeing all
price signals like meltdown in real time
and does it maybe even accelerate from
here i i don't know the answer to that
but i i definitely wouldn't uh write it
off as being
um not what's happening
when you start to look at this right so
let's say that you're one of these bond
investors um or maybe let's take pension
funds pension funds are actually the
better example i think it was uh calpers
uh recently said that they're going to
go ahead and they're gonna start taking
on some uh leverage in their portfolio
they're gonna start uh adding a larger
allocation to alternative assets i see
you grinning right now which uh which
means you know exactly where i'm going
with this uh
i mean is this insane stuff to literally
have a pension fund that's got a
responsibility to millions of pensioners
to say they're gonna take on leverage
everybody who's not who doesn't own
bitcoin
basically has a gun to their head and
they're being told go further out on the
risk curve
it's it's that simple like you you don't
even need to
say anything more than that that's it
and i know people want to hear more
analysis but i mean the analysis is this
if they keep
debasing and manipulating the fixed
income market
which they've been doing for decades
um what they're effectively doing is
just going to every single person and
saying hey you like stocks well now we
really want you to go out on the curve
you want bonds well get in get into the
high yield stuff because that's the only
thing that can
even remotely
look like it's going to outpace your cpi
numbers now and it's not it's it's all
negative the whole thing's negative
so you know people people might look at
the sell-off in bitcoin right now it you
know here we are the day after we're
black friday you get your dis you got
your you got your fire sale uh prices
happening on black friday here
i think it's down i don't know what 20
percent 25 or something right now and
we're
we're uh 54 000 or whatever it is and
people might look at that and say wow
that thing's really scary looking
because it's so volatile
and i just look at it as being
pretty much the only market left in the
world that is not being manipulated
right like no nobody's coming to save
this thing could drop to thirty thousand
nobody's gonna come and save you and
that's why i'm in it
it's because of that
um and i think that what that's gonna do
over time is it's gonna garner more
trust
it's going to be hard for people to bear
the volatility as they don't maybe fully
understand the fundamentals but for
those who do i mean i'm just looking at
this and saying well you got tons of
impairment over in china it looks like
it's starting to spill into the rest of
the of the markets around the world and
that's probably what's you know causing
the sell-off when you're looking at
bitcoin in fiat terms you're looking at
you know a lot of impairment in the
credit markets